سي 9 1 9 اول طائره ركاب كبيره من صنع
الصين كانت قد اجتازت رحلتها الاولى بنجاح
عام 2017 واليوم لم يتبقى الكثير حتى تدخل
الخدمه لكن الطائره الوليد اتواجه معركه
شرسه مع عمالقه الجورب بس الاوروبيه
وبوينج الامريكيه نتعرف على ابرز
الاختلافات
المدى الاقصى لطائره هو
5,550 كيلو متر في حي المدى الاقصى مثلا
8740 كلم من حيث عدد الركاب تستوعب بعض
الطائرات ما يصل الى 230 راكبا
و244 بالنسبه لارباس اما هذه الطائره فلا
يزيد ركابها عن 192 راكبا لكنها تتفوق في
السعر ما يمنحها فرصه للمنافسه في اسواق
عديده حيث يبلغ ثمن الطائره الواحده 99
مليون دولار في حين يبلغ سعر
222 مليون دولار
الطائر الصينيه تعتمد بشكل كبير على
التكنولوجيا الغربيه بما في ذلك المحركات
بالاضافه الى انظمه التحكم في قمه القياده
وحتى العجلات وبشكل عام تتفق على الطائره
الصينيه من حيث كفاءه الوقود لكن ما يثير
قلق الشركه العملاقتين هو احتماليه تاثر
عدد طلبات المستقبليه من الصين تحديدا